well per a number of reports including
ones we looked at earlier donald trump
is getting ready to announce his 2024
republican primary presidential
candidacy number of reasons why he's
looking to do it it seems pretty clear
now it does seem as though
his mood is not quite right donald trump
spent the better part of sunday
afternoon absolutely losing it on truth
social his uh social media platform
whose name even he gets wrong sometimes
he delivered a 14 post screed all within
a short period of time sunday afternoon
and something seems to be very very
wrong uh donald trump starting by
posting a breitbart article about how
mike lee is leading evan mccullen
i believe his name is actually mcmullen
but you know who cares right uh in
utah's senate uh the utah senate's
general election race trump likes mike
lee mike lee is a trumpist then trump
posts an article from the federalist
saying that courts have ruled states
didn't follow their own election laws in
2020.
this is a very popular claim part of the
dozen or two dozen however you know
different claims that are being made by
uh trump republicans about the 2020
election that states didn't follow their
own laws now as we've covered before and
covered pretty extensively uh what they
mean by that
is that in some states
rules about elections were changed
without going through the legislature
that's different than states didn't
follow their own laws what it means is
that
other reasons in particular the pandemic
were used to say actually we're going to
let whoever wants to vote absentee vote
absentee of course they have to go
through the process have to be
registered to vote have to be citizens
all you have to be alive all these
different things and it's just a talking
point the states didn't states broke
their own laws no they're just the the
rules for how to run an election were
modified in ways consistent with the law
trump then posting an article from
townhall.com trump was right they're
sending their rapists now this is of
course related to the story of the 10
year old girl who was tragically raped
and impregnated in ohio and due to
ohio's abortion law had to leave ohio go
to indiana
uh to obtain an abortion
this is now as i said last week the the
thing they're going to focus on at first
they said the story was in was made up
a christie gnome
jim jordan
it's a long list of different people who
said the story is just fake there is no
10 year old girl or if there is she
wasn't raped or if she was raped she
wasn't impregnated if she was
impregnated she didn't really need to go
to indiana well it all happened
it then was learned that the believed
perpetrator
is allegedly undocumented now they care
about the story but not about the part
that we've been talking about so trump
then goes to that
then trump posts an article from hannity
worst president ever after the inflation
report worst president trends on twitter
now of course as i'm sure you know by
now inflation has nothing to do with joe
biden inflation is happening globally
it's much higher than in the u.s in some
countries it's much lower than in the us
in some countries it doesn't have
anything to do with biden trump's just
rapid fire posting this stuff
okay next trump posts the picture
of the alleged rapist in the 10 year old
ohio story
of course
saying that there's a cover-up of the
fact that he's believed to be an illegal
immigrant there is no such cover-up i
reported it to you within the first
minute of telling you the story
the real cover-up is they are covering
up the fact that they called the story
fake for a week until they could no
longer deny it and none of them
apologize for it trump tweeting about
that tweeting sorry
truthing about that
trump then posting an oversized image
related to inflation
and the changes to inflation which of
course
have nothing to do with joe biden so
trump jumping on that one just rapid
fire desperate desperate trump
trump then posting an article from yahoo
news called daily this is john daly a
pro-trump golfer daily calls for british
open return to daddy trump's turnberry
the british open was taken out of
trump's golf course john daly likes
trump and trump signal boosting that
what is trump doing that he has so much
time trump then posting an article from
just the news not a particularly
trustworthy website bombshells undercut
the big lie
21 confirmed illegalities and
irregularities from 2020.
folks
um
150 million votes
150 million votes they have now found
think about this they have now found
after nearly two years
21
instances
of wrongdoing 21
150 million people voted trump wants us
to see it and say wow i guess he was
right then trump with a breitbart
article exclusive trump endorsed senate
candidate mark wayne mullen the red wave
is real and it's coming
meaningless article the red wave may be
coming but all polling is showing a
dramatic shift away from republicans and
towards democrats thanks to what
happened with roe v wade thanks to what
has not happened on gun safety which is
nothing has happened trump then posting
a graph he probably doesn't even
understand exclusive blake masters trump
endorsement has been like rocket fuel
for this campaign
uh maybe i mean okay let's wait and see
what happens there
trump then posting from the
insanely dangerous and weaponized
conspiracy website the gateway pundit
trump appointed judge blox air force
from expelling unvaccinated service
members and enforcing vaccine mandate
just anti-vaxx pablum that we've seen
from trump
trump then with an article from right
side broadcasting another extreme
right-wing media outlet that tim
michaels will win if he remains strong
on the rigged and stolen election trump
says otherwise he has no chance
increasingly untrue actually talking
about the rigged and stolen stolen
election seems to pull worse and worse
even with republican voters and then
donald trump posting a video of mark
levin from fox news
claiming that the january 6th committee
is a setup to quote kill
the republican party
trump then posting a video of sean
hannity talking to laura ingram on fox
news and then donald trump saying the
unselect committee and the fake news
media refused to go anywhere near these
two topics especially the rigged
election where the evidence of fraud is
incontestable this is a former president
folks
just just posting posting posting then
trump posting memes
one about how
people had more savings under trump and
of course the reason for that is
everything was closed and everything
being closed and people just sitting at
home due to the pandemic increased the
savings rate many countries saw that had
nothing to do with trump and by the way
the funniest part about bragging about
the larger savings rate under trump is a
high savings rate is not considered
particularly good for the economy and
what i mean by that is when you save
money in a savings account
you're not injecting it into the economy
it's under traditional economic thinking
which people like trump
claim to believe in and support
um
you don't want people saving you want
people spending this is something they
talk about all the time and then also
donald trump congratulating cam smith on
winning the open championship at saint
andrews okay nobody really cares about
that a 14 post screed
and trump is reportedly panicked about
forthcoming criminal charges and
believed to be announcing his 2024 run
very soon
i have to tell you part of me wonders
and thinks
might be interesting to let him back on
twitter what would he even do if he was
allowed back on twitter
many people are shocked when their
identity is stolen but it's actually one
of the fastest growing crimes in the u.s
i've dealt with it it's a terrible
feeling and that's why i now protect
myself with aura one of our sponsors
aura monitors email addresses passwords
social security number bank accounts
credit cards and i can set it up to
instantly get an alert on my phone if
something happens and then aura goes
through the process of fixing it as well
aura also does things like make sure no
one's opening up bank accounts or credit
cards in your name aura takes all the
tools you need to protect all of your
accounts and devices puts them in one
easy app identity theft protection fraud
monitoring password management antivirus
all in one place at aura.com pacman you
can try aura free for two weeks you can
do things like check whether your login
credentials have been leaked the whole
world might know your email password
right now and you can find out for free
i found an old password in four
different data breaches the link is down
below